a little breather as trading got
underway in Europe this Thursday oil
prices fell by around two dollars a
barrel a glimmer of hope that OPEC plus
producers will get a grip on crude
markets they've surged on Russia's war
in Ukraine could there be consequences
for Moscow
foreign minister Sergey
not only all importance of the oil
cartel at Wednesday's meeting with his
counterparts from the Gulf region but
also of unity
principles of cooperation on this basis
retain their significance
these statements come amid Rumblings in
the oil Alliance
under pressure from Western sanctions
Russia's oil production has dropped by
one million barrels per day meanwhile
prices have exploded
in order to limit price shocks the U.S
is demanding that OPEC increased
production volumes some member nations
are in favor of raising production
quotas but this requires agreement with
Russia
after the United States Russia is the
world's second largest oil producer and
through the OPEC Plus Membership Russia
is bound to the decisions of the other
OPEC countries currently Russia has no
interest in increasing production
volumes and might not technically be in
a position to do so anyway because of
the barrage of Western sanctions a
decision is now on the table to exclude
Russia from the cartel or not
is director of The Village Brandt School
of public policy is Russia going to get
kicked out of OPEC Plus
well I guess that very much depends on
the political signal that OPEC wants to
send I mean there's a couple of
countries that have Spirit capacity
still and uh that's precisely the ones
that are pondering this idea of kicking
Russia out but uh and but on the other
hand the question really is how do you
respond to demands from Washington from
Brussels from the Capitals in Europe and
what is the political signal that you
want to send do you wanna do you want to
align with Russia or do you actually
want to say look we as a cartel we take
Market management seriously and that's
precisely the question OPEC needs to
answer today
is there enough spare capacity there to
offset the drop in Russian production
that we're we're already seeing
there is some spare capacity indeed the
Saudis have Spirit capacity UAE have
spare capacity there is uh discussions
going on uh with Venezuela for the sake
of the argument on whether some of the
sanctions that are still in place could
be lifted possibly increasing Supply
from that country going forward uh so
there is spare capacity in the market
but maybe uh one thing that's important
to bear in mind is we're talking about
2.4 million barrels of oil a day that
Russia sends to Europe every day and
replacing that might be difficult okay
but you say the capacity is there is the
will there because uh so many of these
Middle Eastern Nations have very close
ties to Russia and rely on Russian
wealth
foreign
well they to some extent can hide behind
the Russian uh actions in Ukraine and
that aggressive War uh simply because
they can blame Russia for higher oil
prices uh and and Pockets the windfall
and that's precisely what has been
happening but uh there's another element
which is important and we have seen this
in the past already in the 1970s for
instance when crisis uh were
skyrocketing at some point that the
man's side will respond to the prices
and consumption will go down and that's
precisely not what Saudi Arabia wants in
other countries that want to stay in the
game for some time to come uh to see uh
demand fall I mean surely we would have
to see some sort of shift to uh and a
huge shift to Renewables which is
already underway but probably won't come
quick enough for the ukrainians
certainly not and uh and I think it's
also important to bear in mind there are
some things you can do with Renewables
when it comes to replacing oil but
there's a lot of things you cannot think
about the petrochemical industry you
cannot run them on electrons and that's
precisely where the West uh needs to
probably look at the Mountainside
responses by the way this is happening
already the global economy isn't in
great shape uh we we will see probably a
recession in the Eurozone going forward
the US is not growing as expected nor is
China so we are seeing some demand side
responses already in the shape of
economic contraction and that will
temper demand Andreas coltel thank you
very much for the analysis
thanks for having me